yeah hi everyone welcome to this talk
about an unbiased evaluation of
environment management and packaging
tools and we're really excited to be
here with you today and um yeah before
we jump in a few words about myself I'm
a machine learning engineer at innovex
and innovax is also a diversity sponsor
today so if you want to learn more about
the company come and check out our booth
in my free time I like to work on
personal projects which I usually share
either on GitHub where my handle is so
thrown in eyes and or on my personal web
page where I have a Blog
and two of the most popular repositories
which might be interesting for you as
well are machine learning Basics which
implements fundamental machine learning
algorithms like support Vector machines
perceptron decision trees and so on in
plain python so really
we're the focus on understanding the
algorithms rather than performance and
another one is magical Universe which
introduces python features like
decorators iterators and so on using a
World of Magic so if you like Harry
Potter like I do then you will
definitely enjoy this project
okay
um let's Jump Right In first of all
regarding the goal of this talk
um I think python packaging is quite
messy and if you get into python
understanding which tool to use when
which tool can do what and which tool is
better than the other is really really
hard and um lots of talks exist on the
topic or tutorials but I couldn't find
really an evaluation of the different
tools what they can do which to use when
what they are good for without having
this personal preference in there like
yeah we use this in our project or I had
problems installing this so I don't like
it anymore and this is what I want to do
with this talk I really want to give you
an unbiased evaluation of the available
tools
and what we will do is that we will look
at a categorization first oh yeah by the
way there is also a pdf version on the
slides of the slides online on the page
of the talk if you want to follow along
and we will look at each category in
turn first at a short definition and
motivation and then at the single
purpose tools
and in the end we will also look at the
multi-purpose tools
so um regarding the categorization I
identified five main tasks that are
relevant for packaging and environment
management these are python version
management
package management environment
management which is usually concerned
with virtual environments but doesn't
have to be and we will talk about this
later as well and package building and
Publishing and as you can see here we
have lots of tools for the different
tasks and some can do several tasks on a
single purpose and you will see this
Venn diagram a lot so don't worry if you
can take it in and right now
and if as I mentioned it's also on the
slides in the pdf version
so um let's maybe look at each category
very shortly so you get a first idea
okay let's say python released a new
version and it has some new cool
features that you want to try out and
then you would want to be able to
install different python versions switch
between them easily to um yeah try out
these features and that's what python
version management is about you can see
here there's one single purpose tool we
will look at Pi nth but also some that
have
um that also fulfill other tasks like
conduct
um next category is package management
you should all be familiar with that
since if you work on a project you
usually have dependencies you want to
use other projects and the code and you
would have to install packages usually
with Pip but there are also other tools
um yeah so this is another category
we'll look at again you see here we have
some tools like poetry that can also do
package management but a single purpose
tools pip
um yeah then if you work on projects you
might have several personal projects or
work projects and projects usually have
dependencies and sometimes a project two
projects have the same dependency but
different versions and this can become
very messy so then you usually would use
a virtual environment or an environment
if you use one of the other tools
um and this is what environment
management is about again we have lots
of tools that can do that but in
particular the single purpose tools
would be venfen virtual and which we
will look at but then also some
multi-purpose tools
and yeah let's say now you have your
project you want to share it with other
developers or with the community and so
you want to create a package yourself
then you would first have to build a
package we will talk about what this
means later on as well and you have lots
of tools you can choose from if you want
to build your package
and um in the end then you might want to
publish it to Pi Pi or another index
then you would have to do package
publishing and again lots of tools so
you can see here it again that it can be
really hard to get a grip on those tools
so this was just maybe as a short
um
introduction of the different categories
and now we will work through each of
them individually
so first up is python version management
a tool that can do that is able to
install different python versions or
lets you install them and lets you to
lets you switch between them easily
and why would we want to do that in the
first place
and there are several reasons for
example different projects might require
different versions of python or a single
project support several pylon versions
that you would want to test
and um yeah or you might just want to
check out the newest python version or
an older one and which features it has
to offer
python has a single purpose tool
um which can do that which allows you to
install and many different python
versions which is pi nth quite a popular
tool oh sorry
um
and Pie end was really easy to use so
the most important commands would be
piant install with a certain version now
in this example 3.10.4
but um you also yeah you it also lets
you easily switch between the version
versions you can either activate
um a version just in the current shell
session using pi and shell and the
version number you can set it locally
for the current directory directory
using pi and local and the version or
you set it for your user account using
piant global so Empire is the single
purpose tool for python version
management
okay next up is environment management
usually virtual environments and what
does that mean a tool that can do
environment environment management lets
you create and manage environments which
are usually virtual
why do we want virtual environments I
already talked about this
um yeah usually projects have specific
requirements so they depend on other
packages and usually or often projects
require different versions of a package
and this can cause dependency conflicts
um but yeah you can also get problems if
you just use pip and pip install with a
package name since this places the
package with your system-wide python
installation and which can cause some
problems like system pollution
might have some of you might say no but
there's a user flag now with Pip minus
minus user install
or pip install minus minus user and this
definitely handles some of the problems
but as a beginner some people might not
be aware of that option so you just
should keep in mind there is definitely
a reason to use Virtual environments
lots of reasons to do so
python has two single purpose tools for
this which are venf and virtual amp
which you can see here
um but also some multi-purpose tools but
we will look at them later
so
um venf and virtual length venf is built
in into Python and it's yeah a simple
tool it has one purpose namely creating
and managing virtual environments and um
the most important commands are creating
a virtual environment activating and
deactivating it creating as easy you
choose you just call python minus M
which is the flag to call a module
directly with venfen and the name of
your environment and then you can
activate it by calling Source on the
activate script and I'm deactivating it
by just typing deactivate
but as I mentioned then is is simple too
so um it does not have a lot of features
but
um that's why we have virtual n which
tries to improve vent so it's extendable
it's faster but it also has some other
advantages over vent but you have to
install it so it does not come with
python
and the most important commands are
similar to vent a bit simpler is
creating a virtual environment where you
just call virtual length with the
environment name but again activating
deactivating is the same
as before
okay so we have looked at two categories
already python version management and
environment management
so before we jump into packaging I want
to make sure that we are on the same
page
regarding the two most important files
so um yeah packaging has come a long way
and until pep I think 518 we use
setup.py files to create packages and
then usually setup tools as a build tool
and in pep 518 and the usage of a Pi
Project optimal file was introduced so
right now if you create a package you
will need to create a pi project.tamil
file and this file then replaces this
old setup.py which was used in the past
and pipeproject.tommel contains all
kinds of settings you can have project
settings like the name I have an example
file here from the pandas Library I
don't think you can read it very well
but yeah you have the name you can have
URLs the dependencies but you can also
Define scripts so um it's these the
single file where you would put all your
project and set up and dependencies and
names and so on
um yeah so now we can get into Packaging
um first of all what is packaging or
package management is about downloading
and installing libraries and their
dependencies
and um why would we want to use packages
in the first place
again there are multiple reasons for
that usually
um packages or what is nice about
packages is that they allow you to
create a hierarchy of modules and to
access modules easily so you can import
a package very easily using the dot
syntax like from I don't have a good
example now like from pandas dot
something import something
M sorry about that
um yeah so this makes it easy to use the
code but packages also make it easy to
share code with fellow Developers
and and if you use your Pi predictomal
file to set all the dependencies of the
package other developers can just
install the package and they don't have
to worry about installing all the
dependencies individually they just get
the package code install it and can use
your um use your package or your project
the standard package manager map for
python is PIP so it's the single purpose
tool which you see up there in our Venn
diagram again we have the other multi
multi-purpose tools like pipenf and
conda or um PDM poetry Pi flow which we
will look at later
but you're probably all familiar with
pip pip is shipped with python it is the
standard package manager and it allows
you to install packages either from IPI
but also from other indexes and the main
command is very easy
um it's just pip install with package
name of course there are lots of flags
but we won't get into details here
um Okay so
let's say now
not working
let's say now you want to create your
own package you have code that you want
to put into this nice little box and
share it with the community then you
first have to create or you have first
have to build your package
this means that you have to create
distribution files distribution files
are usually a wheel file dot wheel and
towable files which are DOT target.gz
um one is the source and one is a build
distribution I won't go into details
here but it's yeah interesting to know
about if you want to learn more about
packaging there are lots of resources on
the internet
um okay so python has lots of tools to
do the building step the single purpose
tool which I already mentioned is setup
tools which has been around for a long
time but they are also flit endscons
maturing Pi flow
poetry hatch
so lots of other tools
but as the single purpose tool let's
look at setup tools it was developed as
a buildback end already in 2004 as an
enhancement for disk utils which what
was used at the time you can easily use
setup tools by just specifying it in the
build system section of your Pi
project.tamil file you can see an
example here
and since setup tools is a built backend
not a build front-end you would also in
the end have to use usually the build
tool to build the package and and you
can simply then call python minus and
build
usually and you would most of the people
I know would use a multi-purpose tool to
do this and rather than doing it
manually
like this but you can do it in theory
okay
um now you have your package you have
your distribution files and now you want
to maybe put them on pipei or another
index maybe some private index that's
the step of package publishing
so a tool that allows you to do package
publishing lets you publish the package
to Pi Pi or another index
and in our event diagram we see that
twine is the single purpose tool for
publishing a package but there are also
um the other ones like flit PDM Pi flow
hedge and so on
um yeah twine is the official pipei tool
to upload packages it also works with
other indexes than Pi Pi and yeah it's a
single purpose tool it's just concerned
with uploading or publishing packages
and what you would do is that you upload
the distribution folder so the folder
where you have your wheel and your turbo
files using the command twine upload and
then the folder name
and with the files
okay so now we can get
um into
packaging or the multi-purpose tools but
before we go there I want to do another
short recap namely on lock files
which you might not know
and so in your Pi project.tomel file you
usually Define abstract dependencies so
that means that you just um list the
dependencies without version numbers or
with version ranges but you don't pin
them to exact dependencies that's what
is done in in log file
so a log file contains concrete
dependencies and again here's an example
from poetry and if you can read it or
maybe look at it later on you would see
that it really contains the exact
versions of all dependencies and Sub
dependencies of a package so and this
allows you to do reproducible bills and
really um put everyone on the same page
regarding developing a project
so this is a log file
um
sorry I always have to switch between
those two
okay so regarding our multi-purpose
tools we will start with Pip and which
sits here in our Venn diagram so it can
do environment management and package
management
pip elf has been around for a long time
so as the name says it combines pip and
virtual n
and it introduces two additional files a
pip file which is also a toml file
similar to Pi project.tomo and a log
file which we just saw so you know what
it's about now which is intended to
replace
requirements.txt which was used um or is
maybe still used in some projects
and yeah pip file is used to define your
project dependencies similar to Pi
project.tommel so you would put the name
there the dependencies and so on and the
log file then has the allows you to do
deterministic build so really pins down
every version of every dependency
now um you see the most important
commands here with Pip and if you can
install a package using pip and install
you can run a script using pip and front
but you could also activate a virtual
environment using pip and shell so you
and when you use pip and if you don't
have to manually create virtual
environments anymore the tools doing
that for you using the dependencies that
you specify in PIP file
and then there is conda of course conda
can do everything but benf can do so
python version no sorry environment
management package management and in
addition also python version management
conda is a general purpose package
management system so it's not limited to
python packages and special about conda
is that it uses its own index for
packages so it does not pull them from
Pi Pi conda is a massive tool so it has
a lot of features and I won't go into
more detail here
since again you have we'll find multiple
resources to learn more about conda
now we can look at our packaging tools
and since I promised an unbiased
evaluation of them
I came up with a list of features that I
think are important regarding packaging
tools and we will look at each tool now
and these features so does the tool
allow you to manage dependencies does it
resolve and lock dependencies so does it
also create a log file does it have a
clean flow for building and Publishing a
package does it allow you to use plugins
and does it support the two made or
there are lots of peps on packaging but
I think these two are important since
the projects differ and so one is if the
project supports pep 660 which is about
installing packages in editable mode
so um pip for example allows you to do
that and what that means is that if
you're developing a package and you want
your changes to be like you install the
package and then you work on the package
and add new features and you want those
changes to be directly available in your
environment then you would install the
package in editable mode so it's quite
an important feature to have if you are
developing something
and pep 6 under 21 is about how you
specify your project metadata in Pi
Project automl so it sets a standard way
on how to do that that's nice to have
but not
um like develop development feature
um okay so let's start with the first
tool which is flit so flit as you can
see in our Venn diagram has a very
specific use case it's only about
building and Publishing packages
um yeah this is just in text again what
we just saw in our Venn diagram it does
not care about managing your python
versions about packaging and managing
packages or environments it's just about
building and Publishing a package
slit um is special since it has a very
specific use case first of all it's just
for python pure python packages so if
you have any extension code like in C
plus plus then you could not use flit
since flit is just for pure python
packages so those that don't would not
need the build step
and yeah it only cares about packaging
and that's also reflected in our feature
table so it has a clean flow for
building and Publishing a package and
supports the two peps however does not
allow you to use plugins it's um
yeah it doesn't care about resolving or
locking dependencies or managing them
since it's just really for the
publishing and building of a package but
it's very easy to use so you can use
flit in it which would create a new Pi
project.tamil file for you and if you
then want to build and publish your code
then you would use flit publish which is
doing both steps for you and if you have
dependencies you would have to add them
manually to Pi project.t Thomas so we
will see now in a bit that there are
some tools which have commands to do
that
okay and next up is poetry
um which sits here in our Venn diagram
quite small the name but you can see
that it can do everything except for
python version management
here's in text form once um again so
um yeah it fulfills all of these tasks
um if we look at our feature list
then we can see that it does not support
pep 621 which is interesting that has
been an open GitHub issue for that for
about one and a half years I think
but all the other main things are
supported like it allows you to use
plugins it has a locking and a locking
functionality and resolve your
dependencies for you and allows you to
manage dependencies
and which is also reflected in the main
command so you can create a directory
structure so it would create an empty
test directory
um your Pi project.tamil file but also
the dunder init files and so on for you
using poetry new and the project name
you can also create only the Pi Project
terminal file interactively using poetry
in it which would prompt you to provide
the basic information about your package
like the name the description and so on
and you can use poetry install to
install a package from API project.tomel
file and what is happening here is that
poetry looks at the Pi Project Tamil
file at all the dependencies it resolves
all the dependencies and it also
installs them for you
um yeah then package dependency
management or package management
is also implemented so there is the
command poetry ad with a package name
which would install the package but also
write the package into your Pi Project
tunnel file for you so what you don't
have to do that manually
and yeah there's a nice command to look
at all your dependencies in a tree
format using poetry show with a tree
flag
um yeah running code is also easy you
can either activate your virtual
environment which is created for you
using poetry shells so then you have a
shell session with the virtual
environment activated or you can run
scripts using poetry run I mentioned
that earlier that in pi project.com you
can also Define scripts for your project
so and those you could run with poetry
run but you can also run everything else
like poetry run and then python script
name
um for running your python script
um it may be good to know is that if you
use poetry shell and your virtual
environment is activated there then you
would not need poetry run anymore then
you could just call Python and your
script
and um regarding the log file so poetry
has a locking functionality so when you
install a package for the first time
poetry will resolve all dependencies for
you and write the exact versions of all
those dependencies into the poetry.log
file and it's best practice or
recommended to publish that log file
with your project so
um you allow other developers or
contributors to really have the exact
versions of the packages and
dependencies installed
and um if you once created your log file
it's not updated automatically but you
can do that with the Poetry poetry
update command
and yeah it's also very easy to build
and publish a package using poetry build
poetry publish
um poetry build creates the distribution
files for you and poetry publish would
put um put them on Pi Pi if you have a
pipei user name and password
and what you will see is that in general
for these multi-purpose or packaging
tools the commands are all very similar
so you will see this build and publish
command like in every tool
okay next up is PDM
and PDM is strongly inspired by pi flow
and um also poetry that's why it sits
right where poetry sits in our diagram
and um yeah it can do everything except
for python version management just like
poetry
um
yeah since it was strongly inspired it
has very similar features but it's a
rather new project and it was started in
2019 I think so it requires python 3.7
or higher and it's one of the few tools
that implements pep 582 which is an
alternative to using virtual
environments so
um it's based on so-called local
packages and not on Virtual environments
um and yeah check out the pep if you're
interested this pep is currently under
consideration so it's not it hasn't been
accepted or
um yeah implemented widely yet
um PDM supports all of the features on
our list so it supports the major peps
it allows you to use plugins and you can
easily build and publish a package and
it has a locking functionality and
allows you also to manage your
dependencies
um yeah as you can see now here very
similar commands but PDM has a bit fewer
commands than poetry like there is a PDM
image command which would allow you to
create your Pi product or terminal file
interactively but there is no command
that would create the whole directory
structure for you
the install command is similar to poetry
it would read the Pi Project terminal
file resolve all dependencies and
install the packages for you
and then dependency management is easy
you can use PDM ad with a package name
this would get the package from Pi Pi
and look for the correct version that
does not conflict with your other
dependencies and then put that into your
Pi project.tumble file the package name
and again you can easily look at your
dependencies that you currently have
using PDM list
M running code and there is no command
like PDM shell which would activate a
virtual environment in your current
shell but you can always use PDM run
which then implicitly runs your scripts
within a virtual environment that has
all the dependencies installed that you
need
foreign
also the log file functionality is very
similar so when you install a package
for the first time all your concrete
versions all your exactly pin
dependencies will be written to pdm.lock
and you can also update that file using
PDM update
and yeah building publishing very
similar you have a PDM build command it
creates the wheel and toggle files and
PDM publish to put them on Pi Pi or
another index
and um yeah last but not least we have
hatch
um
hedge allows you to do these three
things so um it is it allows you to do
environment management and building and
Publishing a package
you can also see that here regarding
python version management there is an
open GitHub issue but it was just
created a few months ago and regarding
package management this is something
that is being worked on and the core
developer said that he wanted to add the
Locking interface
um by the US pycon which I think was
last weekend so maybe it's already now
implemented
so while locking interface package
management basically comes down to being
able to lock and resolve dependencies
and that's why it's currently not
implemented but will be in the future
now um yeah this is also reflected in
our feature list since um the Locking
functionalities that's not implemented
yet you cannot manage dependencies or
resolve them but it will be added at
some point
um but all the other features are
available and also the peps are
supported
um and yeah now the main commands
um
you can create your directory structure
um using hedge new with a project name
there's also an interactive mode for
this using the minus I flag
and you can initialize an existing
project using hatch new and the init
command and this would also convert
setup.py files into a pi project.tamil
files
so it's nice to use if you have an old
project and you want to come convert it
into the new standard
dependency management is not implemented
as I mentioned so there is no command
like hatch add but you can easily you
get look at your dependencies using
hatch depth and then show for example as
a table format now if you have
dependencies with hatch you would also
have to put them into your Pi Project or
terminal file manually
and running code there's a shell command
which would activate a virtual
environment in the current shell or um
you can also use head run to run all
kinds of scripts or just python commands
and yeah same as before so and there is
building and Publishing with this simple
straightforward commands build and
publish
and now one cool thing
um about hatch is that it allows you to
declare your environments in your Pi
product or terminal file so there is a
section there I don't have time left if
we want to do questions but um this is
definitely a feature to check out so you
could have one environment for style
checks or I'm formatting your code where
you have the dependencies like black I
sword flag 8 which are just concerned
with that and scripts defined on that
you could have one or declare one
environment for building your
documentation with mkdocs and I really
like organized structured things so I
love this about head
and dammit now I'm putting some bias
into this presentation
so um yeah this is a cool feature which
is special about head
and now before we get to the question
here you have an overview about the
tools and this is also an important
takeaway there is not the single best
tool in Python to do packaging so um
sometimes if you just want to do a use a
virtual environment but don't create a
package then maybe event for virtual and
Vista tool to use but um regarding
packaging
um it depends on maybe what your team is
using that you all maybe use the same
tool that you're familiar with the tool
and that it's easy to use and actively
developed but this is a big
discussion there's a big discussion
going on in the python ecosystem at the
moment regarding packaging since um
there are so many different tools and
it's hard to really say this is the
single best one
yeah sorry if you expect it now that I
give you the best solution for your
problems
um okay this is the end thank you very
much for listening and now we have time
for questions which you can ask on
I forgot the name
yeah slido thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much that was a really
interesting talk I was very happy to
listen to it
we got a lot of really interesting
questions
the one that was the most popular is
would you recommend PDM over poetry and
if so why
you and your
opinions and oh wow difficult questions
um
no I can't really give a good answer to
that I wouldn't recommend one tool over
the other I know that some people have
issues with poetry since um at one point
they pushed a new change and didn't and
warn the users before in this bro code
for some people and that's oh I know
some people don't like poetry but for me
it always worked well I haven't worked
so much with PDM yet so um yeah maybe
not the best person to answer the
question if that's really a better tool
the next popular question is which of
these tools has the best stocks
community
um Okay so
my personal favorite would be hatch
since it's so actively developed and I
think the core developer is just doing
all this development with a mouse since
he's disabled and I find that really
impressive and um
I think it has a very cool set of
features and very friendly
contributors so
um yeah I really
like that about hatch
thanks so the next question in the line
is how would you package code for an
offline installation
on the customer server that's quite
specific but interesting question
how would you package
I think I have to um to think about that
so maybe the person that asked that can
come to come to see me later then I can
think about it before I give a wrong
answer
thank you the next question is pi flow
was in the middle but you didn't mention
this in your presentation why yeah sorry
I forgot um to mention that so I didn't
have time to get into all of the tools
and Pi flow um hasn't been actively
developed for a long time so that's why
I decided I had all the slides ready
but then I decided to um since I had to
um yeah focus on some tools to not
present it since I think active
development in the python ecosystem and
especially on packaging is a really
really important feature and working
with a project that is not actively
developed is um can be really frustive
frustrating
thanks
the next question is environment
management needed with Docker or packet
management is enough
yeah I think and those are different use
cases since
um if if you think now about a beginner
in programming
um Docker is not the first thing that
you learn about and that you use
so um I think virtual environments are
really important for for this other use
case where you would not use stalkerized
or containerized applications
um
but then yeah that that works also just
to use um Docker and your containers
thank you that's a question there are so
many questions yeah we won't get to all
of them
uh you mentioned some tools of python
only how would and that's a broad
question so you may not have to answer
all of it what how would the diagram
change if C plus plus Juliet Center are
considered I'm assuming it's extensions
and not the whole ecosystem and not just
the whole ecosystem but if you're
including extension what the diagram
change
I think I don't think I understand the
questions like what
um so for example Maturin and end cons
which you saw in the beginning those are
also one I think is for rest code
um yeah here
um and only flit is a tool that is for
Pure python packages so the Other M
dependencies managers also work if you
have extension code does that answer the
question not sure if I understood the
question otherwise just ask me later on
we can discuss that
cool
um
what tools do you recommend for building
packages that are only to be used
internally
um okay so I don't think the internal
thing is um the important Point since
um it is more important that you can use
the tool nicely and I already spoiled at
my personal tool a favorite at the
moment is hatch so I would always
recommend hatch now to people
and to use
that ties in nicely with the question
next question which is what is your
stack
okay
um that depends if um I'm at work it
really depends on which customer project
I work with and what um
um is used in the corporate environment
so
um
yeah that can be lots of different tools
so um of course a lot of Docker
kubernetes
um
um well there are so many different
tools we started using snowflake now
recently
um we're just not so popular yet but I
think we'll definitely come I've worked
with the data breaks at customers so
um yeah most of my work is at work time
so it really depends on what the
customers are using
related to going into their opinions are
there any tools you would not recommend
no
you have to um yeah
build your own opinion great great
um next question thanks for the
interesting thought can you summarize
gifts some tips on how to combine conda
and pip
I am
no no not not like right now
um I know that it's possible to combine
them I have never combined them myself
and I usually always use these
multi-purpose tools and I've since I
find them quite convenient and um yeah
nice to structure my work
um and I always like in my personal
projects I always keep it simple since
it's rather tutorial based or
educational projects but at work we're
always in big teams with many people
usually and that's why the multi-purpose
tools can be very helpful
so yeah sorry no but I know that there
are tutorials out there
thank you there were a bunch of
questions related to condo the main one
center around why is it not in the
center and what did it Miss in the
summer
um so it's not in the centers since
yeah it maybe maybe I'm wrong now but um
I don't think that conda is concerned
with building and Publishing packages is
that wrong
much
for example
it says
yeah but that is
yeah but um now here in our Venn diagram
building and Publishing would be that
um conda has a command or a tool that
okay then it's wrong
that's definitely wrong thanks yeah
and maybe your last question for today
in the evaluation is poetry does not
have a tick in the last straw metadata
but also supports Pi Project common
what's the difference okay so um this
new pep is about how you specify the
metadata and Pi project.com not that
it's in there but how it's formatted so
how exactly you provided and um there
the pep came after introducing pi
project.tomel and then
um recommended a way how you should
specify it and
a poetry of course also contains the
metadata but it has its own way on how
it's provided are specified
thank you we have time for one last
question and there's one that has been
uh well asked several times on different
versions which is
uh which of the Sean package Community
rebuilds pet packages for a new python
versions or a different platform so
there's a question about how the the
packages are being rebuilt
I'm sorry can you repeat that
yes the question was
which of the show package communities
rebuilt packages for new python versions
or different platforms so in other words
how are the package I think it's a
question around how are the patricage
index is being kept up to date
for the different package managers I
don't know that
I would have to to look it up
cool then that concludes our q a section
today to give another huge round of
applause
[Applause]